hello everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel
in this session we will learn how to
implement a stack
using an array in c programming but
before we begin
let me tell you guys that we have daily
updates on multiple technologies
if you are a tech geek and a continuous
hunt for latest technological trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn
now without further ado let's get
started with our session for today
so let's have a brief look on the agenda
we will begin with what exactly
is a stack then we will understand
operations on stack
then we will see how to implement a
stack
using array and finally we will
implement
a stack using array practically i hope i
made myself clear with the agenda
now let's get started with our first
topic that is what is a stack
so a stack is a linear data structure
that follows
fifo or first in first out principle
all the operations on the stack are done
only
from one end that is the top
so you can see this image here and this
particular image of box can be
considered as
stack and you can see that the addition
or elimination of elements that are
spokes in this particular case
is happening only through the top
section
now we will understand what are the
basic operations that can be performed
on a stack
so the basic operations that can be
performed on a stack are
push pop and peak
so this particular image on the right
side will help you understand what
exactly is
push pop and peak as we discussed the
elements will be added
into the stack from the top so when you
add an element
from the outside into the stack it will
be pushed from the top
that is the push operation and if you
want to eliminate an element from the
stack
it will be eliminated from the top that
is the pop operation
apart from these two that is push and
pop we have another operation that
is called as peak the main intention of
p
is just to see the element which is on
the topmost part of the stack
it will just retrieve the element from
the top it will not
pop it or it will not push any other
element onto the top it will just
copy and it will just print what is
present on the top
so these are the main operations that is
push pop and peak
now let us see how to implement this
stack
using array so implementation of stack
data structure can be done
in two ways that is array and linked
list
now in this particular session we will
learn how to
implement stack using array data
structure
now without further ado let's get
started with the implementation of stack
so we will be performing push operation
that is inserting a new element into the
stack
now followed by that we will be
performing the pop operation onto the
stack
that is eliminating or deleting an
element from the top position of the
stack
and followed by that the last operation
that is the peak operation
where we will be just retrieving the
topmost element from the stack
without removing that element from the
stack or without adding any new element
to the stack
now that we have a detailed
understanding of what are the basic
operations that can be applied onto the
stack
let's get started with the practical
implementation
now you can see that on my screen we
have the basic
fundamental operations onto stack that
has the push and pop
now without further ado let's get
started with running this code
don't worry about the code this
particular code will be present
in the description box below or if you
need it you can always write down to us
in the comment section below and we will
have it sent to your mail id
so that you can have a better
understanding of the code and try to
execute the code
in your local system now let's run the
code and see the output
as you can see the code got successfully
executed and
the topmost element is a and the topmost
element
is b after the element is being popped
away and
it says that the element b was popped
out and after that the topmost element
was a
and after that the element a was also
popped out
and now the top is pointing to -1
which means to say that the stack is
empty
so with that we have come to an end of
this tutorial on stack implementation
using array data structure
if you have any queries regarding the
topics covered in this tutorial
or if you need the code that we have
used in this particular tutorial then
please feel free to let us know in the
comment sections below
and we will have your queries solved as
early as possible
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here